[Music]
earlier this week I issued a challenge
to our viewers to see I said to my
viewers if you can find a mistake on our
show just look and see if you can find a
mistake all right and then tell us about
it
I dared my viewers to try and make chunk
meat out of the master well ladies and
gentlemen the responses have been
pouring in
so far three viewers this week have
challenged me three have gone down in
flames well now here's the latest a fan
named Corey says he thinks he found a
mistake he posted a video on YouTube
where he comments on my interview last
night with the famous Teddy Roosevelt
biographer edmund morris check it out
howdy Conan big fan my name is Corey I'm
also a really big Theodore Roosevelt fan
in fact this is my Teddy Roosevelt GI
Joe that sits on my desk
anyways I noticed in your interview with
mr. Morris that you said his two terms
which isn't right he's both his Dennis
two terms one of those terms was not his
it was William McKinley's that he
finished after President McKinley was
shot at the pan-american expose by Leon
toll cause so you were wrong I guess I'm
a chump need out of you because you
can't argue with history
nice try Cory but here's a little news
flash for you you're dead wrong if you
were half the Teddy Roosevelt expert you
claim to be you'd be familiar with this
famous piece of very rare historical
footage I was with McKinley when he died
and his last words were damn the
technicalities if I die this is your
term and if you want to be elected on
your own it will mean you serve two
terms case closed
[Applause]
[Music]
and here's another thing okay McKinley
was shot at the pan-american exposition
what did you say again Cory after a
President McKinley was shot at the
pan-american expose by Leon Togo's
pan-american expose look here carrot-top
maybe you should
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Who am I to mock you
okay a carrot top
maybe you should spend more time
studying history and less time playing
with your dolls anyway anti doll crown
yeah I don't know about the hair but the
doll things crazy
Tori I have that same doll anyway the
challenge still stands okay if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
reported at teen koco.com slash haha I
found an error send us a link to your
video explanation as pathetic as it may
be and we'll sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chopped meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]